alors y'a aussi bien aux silences board
link est un acteur qu'on n'a pas vu
depuis des années un acteur américain
absolument génial et un grand comique
américain qui s'appelle eddy lizard qui
est un type fabuleux l'agent pierre
gravillons également mais qui fait pas
un grand rôle mais qu'on voit dans une
scène de bagarre au fond à gauche
alors on pense qu'en tant quand on voit
ce film on pense aux grands films des
années 70 pas moi en tous les cas du
temps un pays connu parce que ça fait
penser un peu à 2001 odyssée de l'espace
la traversée comme ça à travers des
effets vers la barre lier vers l'infini
les espaces infinis et l'ours qui est
extraordinaire dans le film c'est que
c'est du cinéma non figuratif et ça
c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau
c'est à dire que quand ils les visions
que blueberry à après avoir bu la la
décoction des chamans n'a finalement on
voit des choses qu'on voit quand on
prend de l'acide convoi quand on prend
des champignons hallucinogènes et c'est
retranscrit sur un écran de cinéma
et ça je crois que c'est la première
fois qua non je dirais que c'est ce type
d'expérience c'est sur l'essence dans un
moment donné il faut il faut essayer de
non pas de regarder et d'essayer de
comprendre vraiment avec son esprit ce
que ça veut dire essayer de le ressentir
avec les images la musique et le son
c'est le voyage intérieur
ça a bien relancé les ventes d'acide ce
truc je suis pas sûr il faut bien qu'on
pas comprendre deux choses c'est que le
chamanisme par exemple ces nounous ce
nous nous sommes les primitifs de notre
culture
quand nous allons vers les psychotropes
parce qu on le fait de manière festive
et on oublie tout on se perd un peu et
on en garde un rien faut penser qu' ils
font ça pour soigner c'est quand même un
mystérieux et donc quand vous prenez ces
plantes avec les indiens
ça se passe dans le noir général vous
venez vous faire soigner pour tous les
indiens est en tout cas ce n'est pas que
festif c'est que ça génère des frayeurs
effectivement quand vous dites qu'on ait
des primitifs par rapport à eux c'est un
peu le côté little big man du film c'est
à dire que little big man c'était un
film où pour la première fois je crois
qu'on voyait des indiens on admettait
que les indiens avaient plus de
connaissances que nous sur le plan
spirituel
alors vous allez profiter tous les deux
des repérages pour vous initier quand
même un peu au chamanisme non vous avez
un moment
soit les partis dans un an on a dit
kunal il est parti en rit quand même en
revenant d'un repérage
vous avez décidé quand même d'arrêter le
cinéma bah oui c'est vrai qu'à un moment
donné
et on va chercher l'inspiration comme un
artiste en disant avec respect et puis
en fait dans ce genre de sujet moment
donné vous voulez retourner c'est plus
du cinéma
yann donc vous vous avez pratiqué donc
là-bas en amazonie lors des repérages et
vincent aussi si vous aviez fait une
petite psychanalyse il ya quelques
années mais pas très pas très fort et
puis d'un seul coup c'est la grande
claque non j'imagine que quand j'ai vu
ian partir comme ça de l'autre côté de
la planète pourra les synergies mais
physiquement là dedans pour alors que
moi c'est resté vraiment du domaine du
livre et revenir en racontant des
aventures absolument incroyable et c'est
ma proposé de venir l'accompagner un
moment et en fait je me suis désisté
deux fois parce que ça me faisait peur
et j'ai fini par y aller et quand je
suis revenu j'ai compris pourquoi ça
nous faisait peur parce qu'avec c'est
effectivement c'est terrifiant c'est
terrifiant puisque si tout d'un coup le
chamanisme et une manière de en fait
d'appréhender son inconscient en étant
éveillé il se trouve que l'inconscience
cd rêve mais c'est aussi des cauchemars
d'où la nécessité d'un chaman avec soi
c'est à dire que la tendance à sortir la
substance du contexte hélas il faut là
c'est vraiment c'est depuis l'avion
avant de partir europ assistance parce
que j'avais été rapatriés on a dit
beaucoup de choses sur ce film et sur
route voilà une phrase dans le film
c'est justement affronter peur et tu
seras qui tu es dit le chemin et c'est
une phrase qui finalement résume résume
tout à fait le film alors vous ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que les visions
yann que vous avez eue
vous avez dessiné ou fait dessiner et
vous les avez soumises à des chats mans
qui les reconnaissent qui les nomme et
qui les corrige ça veut dire que
finalement quand on on prend ce genre de
substance et qu'on en arrive à les
traduire visuellement
finalement ça rejoint d'autres vision
qu'ont eu d'autres êtres humains qu'on
est déjà qualifiés
si ça et puis une expérience qu'ils
avaient fait un moment donné de donner
ces substances à
dix gènes à des inuit qui n'avait jamais
rien vu jamais vu de serpents et qui
avait dessiné un animal qui ne
connaissais pas qui était un serpent
donc là c'est le mystère et ça rejoint
des archétypes youm bien dans le voilà
c'est dans l'inconscient collectif il
faut et c'est fort mais pendant le
tournage
quand vous jouez les scènes à vous en
buvez vraiment du très bon c'est quelque
chose qui en fait c'est un psychotrope
qui est beaucoup trop puissant pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir l'utiliser sur un
plateau ce genre il est en conclave de
l'ecstasy en fait c'était trop non mais
disons qu'en fait c'est vrai que le fait
d'avoir été donc faire ses calculs
voyage dans la jungle et avoir participé
à des sessions chamanique
j'avais un j'avais de quoi puiser enfin
j'avais un souvenir assez précis de ce
que c'était mais sur un plateau il ya
plus de plateaux mais c'est quand
l'équipe nous a pris pour des cinglés ce
qui s'est passé c'est que c'était la
première fois qu'on tournait une c'est
donc une séance de transe chamanique
pour le film et donc on a commencé je
crois vers 8 heures du soir et
commençait à faire nuit et puis on
tournait en tournée vont en effet une
techno craignent donc yann tournait
autour de moins avec la techno crenn et
c'était bien je crois ce qu'on vous ait
été déjà été déjà assez carré et je
crois que ça pouvait faire la faire et
je regardais le combo donc le moniteur
et je me disais mais c'est bizarre il ya
quelque chose qui est trop bon contrôle
en fait si je me rappelle bien dans ces
moments là j'étais vraiment complètement
à l'envers et il ya un moment où il ya
un photographe qui est venu et qui
étaient toujours au mauvais endroit sûr
ce sur ce plateau et il est venu un
juste avant entre action et entre le
moteur et action et ça m'a énervé et
j'ai eu un truc envers lui assez violent
et en fait ça m'a fait basculer et à ce
moment là ça commence à partir dans un
truc beaucoup plus étrange que ce que
j'avais fait plus le début de la soirée
et je sentais que yann s'arrêter plus de
tournées dont je me concernant je me
disais je suis dedans je suis dans celle
dans entre les prix je voyais sève le
pointeur qui ne nous regardait plus dans
les yeux
jeudi à l'ats il ya un truc il ya un
truc qui a basculé qui commence à
déraper ça peut être pas mal il vivre
une voie à ce moment là il m'a fait
continuer comme ça les clips nous prend
pour des fous là j'ai explosé de rire
et malheureusement il y avait plus de
pellicules mais on a tourné comme un
rempart contre le moment on a ri je
crois que l'équipe nous a pris encore un
peu plus pour des fous et c'était en
fait je ne savais pas tout ce qu'on
allait rajouter par la suite les
producteurs ont eu peur ce jour là parce
qu'on a utilisé l'équivalent d'une
semaine de pellicule en une nuit on n'a
pas arrêté de tourner et on a fini de
tourner il devait être 5 heures du matin
le jour se lever je suis allé voir yann
je dis tu vois si ça avait été un autre
acteur très galéré pour lui expliquer et
m'a dit bien ce soir j'ai compris
pourquoi c'était toi qui devait faire le
film et là j'ai pris l'avion et je suis
parti à cannes pour présenter un autre
univers celui d' irréversible
j'ai fais pas ci très sérieuse aussi
quand c'est très sérieux donc oui
c'était le passage d'un dans cet univers
où on était vraiment là où on était il y
avait rien n'est pas d'électricité pas
d'eau pas de téléphone forcément on est
honteux dans la majorité des marchés
avec monica bellucci donc et la presse
et tout le bordel que ça que ça que ça
suscite et le vivement plus qui laissait
pas les gens indifférents
c est la vue blueberry monica bellucci
monica bellucci a vu libérer bien sûr et
alors je ben je crois qu'elle a beaucoup
apprécié et blueberry hill a vu manica
la joie et la voir vous dit en parlant
d'elle je comprends qu'elles fassent
autant rêver les hommes puisque moi
aussi elle elle me fait rêver
oui je pense à vous des fois je vous
jure c'est vrai je me dis je me dis sa
nouvelle série pour vous quand elle pas
retourner à l'étranger comme ça pendant
trois mois et non franchement on
sérieusement funeral home et le moment
je suis en train de tourner à l'étranger
aussi vous savez il faut mettre des
bulles un peu ça mais de l'air
la liberté c'est ce qui fait durer les
choses ouais alors le 31 800 film de
frédéric schoendoerffer avec monica
bellucci et vous alors au départ après
six mois de blueberry vous ai dit je
vais pas retravailler sur l'expérience a
été a été trop forte et puis finalement
à ce moment là monica est dans le projet
de du film de sean dorfer et vous dites
je vais faire le film parce que comme ça
je la bloque pendant trois mois donc je
me dis quand même que quand je me fais
du souci pour lui j'ai un peu raison
parce que quand même quand vous pouvez
la bloquer trois mois faisait longtemps
comme c'est gentil vous inquiétez pour
moi on est vraiment parce que je trouve
vous avez une femme sublime mais merci
merci vraiment et j'ai compris non c'est
vrai limite aucune chance
à sa vie allait changer cela
à rien puisqu'on parle d'avenir on va
parler un petit peu aussi de ocean's
twelve qui est la suite de ocean eleven
avec clooney brad pitt julia roberts et
andy garcia vous allez revenir
d'hollywood après la wii alors d'abord
on tourne par hollywood
on tourne dans l'europe ah ouais ouais
pourquoi je me fais pas écouté
soderbergh vient me voir à cannes il me
dit j'ai vu irréversible j'ai vu sur mes
lèvres j'ai vu la haine j'ai un job pour
toi je dit écoute ses voeux je t'aime
bien non mais j'ai dit pourquoi pas
évidemment et tu es quand il me fait
lire le script et je me rends compte que
ce n'est pas de méchants français bien
au contraire il pourrait devenir
français de les angles aba comme charles
boyer je ne deviens pas de france et de
hollywood
et qui plus est le rôle qui me propose
c'est le plus grand cambrioleur du monde
oui vous allez je vous dis ça se prend
sastre mais vous êtes assez solide par
rapport aux tentations financière à vous
dit que finalement si on est assez de
blé pour bouffer faut pas faire
n'importe quoi pour l'argent vous gérez
votre carrière plutôt plutôt bien quand
même assez merci une fois passé je vais
vous présenter votre femme
d'accord
je ne suis pas du tout un à 7,1 mais jeu
j'essaye de faire un peu plus d'argent
que juste pour manger
j'aime beaucoup voyager etc mais dis
donc je ne pense que coûte et pour faire
un film on fait un film il faut le
sortir sortir un film c'est ce que j'ai
en train de faire en ce moment et ce
soir puisque j'ai fait depuis un mois
avec la presse les trucs les marchands
etc
c'est exténuant et je pense que c'est
très mauvais pour la santé morale et je
me dis il faut pas trop en faire quand
il vaut mieux être venu acceptait
disparaître un petit peu trop longtemps
et revenir avec des projets aussi
marquant que celui qui a réalisé yann
plutôt que d'enchaîner des trucs pour
pourquoi faire c'est taxiway je crois
j'ai l'impression que les gens en chaîne
ou alors parce qu'ils ont peur de
disparaître complètement
ou alors parce que ils ont besoin
d'amasser quelque chose pour je sais pas
quoi faire ce qu'ils ont peur de manquer
ça voilà je crois que les gens ont peur
de mon gros ils viennent accompagne
tourné pendant des années donc mais j'ai
eu la chance d'être gâtés très tôt j'ai
attaqué assez vite avec des films que je
que j'apprécie beaucoup je pense à la
haine même à métis donc en fait je suis
pas inquiet c'est peut-être alors
justement on parle de métis avec
kassovitz je vais faire ma vie donne
bébébiz d'après le bouquin de dantec ça
vous gêne pas dans les déclarations
enfin vous ça vous gêne sûrement mais
j'imagine que kassovitz aussi les
déclarations de de dantec sur le bloc
identitaire
parce que là maintenant comme il
soutient ouvertement alors ce qu'il a
vraiment dit ça j'ai pas suivi en fait
il a réellement dit mais c'est un
problème effectivement c'est un problème
que j'explique à nos amis
téléspectateurs donc maurice dans le
tech est un écrivain chez gallimard
plutôt plutôt plutôt intéressante voilà
je dois intéressant qui d'un seul coup
commence à partir un peu comme
houellebecq quand il avait déclaré que
l'islam est la religion la plus con du
monde d'ailleurs houellebecq maintenant
fréquentent les raéliens donc c'est vrai
que ça commence à venir bizarre et
dantec pareil dantec café des bouquins
plutôt bien d'un seul coup il se met en
liaison avec le bloc identitaire qui est
finalement ce qui a remplacé unité
radicale telle unité radicale c'est le
mec qui a voulu tuer chirac au 14
juillet est tout à fait dantec tient des
propos mais terrifiant sur sur les
arabes sur les musulmans écoutez je sais
pas quoi vous diront ce que je sais
c'est que j'ai lu un scénario maintenant
il ya un
tu pourrais faire un film est vraiment
extraordinaire donc maintenant je sais
pas où ça en est le film est annoncé
j'ai pas lu dès que la déclaration en
question mais je vais les ya un article
dans le point cette semaine
et voilà vous garderez vous
vincent va faire une petite interview
simple un hardi view
oui
vous pensez à quoi là je me dis merde
pourquoi parce que je pensais échapper à
ce genre de trucs ouais vous dites quoi
le matin quand vous regardez dans le
miroir je me dis bon encore une qui
commence on n'a qu'à se dire qu'on a de
la chance vous auriez aimé ressembler à
qui quand vous étiez petit petit petit
spider man
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
mal c'est en existe pas de conneries ça
fait un petit moment en ont peut-être
que c'est des trucs là que je lis en ce
moment dans la presse quand ya les gens
qui comprennent pas le film ça m'énerve
moi j'ai vu que des bons papiers sur le
film il ya eu un truc qui m'a énervé les
gens dit il ya un mec qui a écrit que le
sud était chip et je les prie pour moi
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois dans blueberry way dans une scène
mais pour le rôle oui oui pour le roi
mais sinon on devrait aller aux jeux
réponse que je veux voir un haka
il songe auriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique un peu moins
des goûts ouais ouais ben le reste c'est
vrai qu'elle est le péché qui vous tente
le plus la luxure
ouais avec ta femme rejette qui avez
vous le plus envie d'épater
déjà moi ouais ouais
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites le soir avant de vous coucher une
petite brunette d'ego qui pensent qu'à
toi les gens le comprennent mal le
l'homme est il avec monica bellucci ça
c'est qu'il ya un problème énorme
vincent que pourriez-vous dire de plus
négatif sur vous qui vient de le faire
bonne réponse qu'est ce que je pourrais
dire de plus négatif sur moi là tout de
suite tu es vraiment à chier dans
blueberry nights vous n'êtes pas
d'accord ça fait plaisir
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi pour le moment pas grand
chose
1 en même temps c'est vrai quand on voit
beau film de votre femme c'est vrai
qu'on se dit dans le fond mais à face à
bien des problèmes dans la vie
1 il ya bien des points faibles
barrières tu le sais bien
ah non moi j'ai un gros est ce qu avez
vous fait vincent que nous ne sachions
pas alors justement restons-en là vous
avez menti durant cette interview bien
sûr que non
se renseigner
vincent merci iliad merci on vous laisse
filer je vous dis merde pour le film
m
ça va marcher way